hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to de-spawn it's y'all
we got an angry water monster over there
we got one gear over here we three told
the burner burner derp derp derp derp
never knows what's dimming that they're
just gonna be scattered around this
basement area ah there's another one up
spank you deep rude of you thank you ah
you can't get me water monster ah badge
I can't uh I can't jump know where he is
kind of feel like he's stuck on
something and does not fit on that spoke
ooh did I actually press either way I
got it good OOP oh [ __ ] up oh crap Boop
yep yeah there is
okay I should not look at that guy
nothing
Hey look some oil I see that I like it
up there
OOP oh that's smack aah I got this you
got this watch on the other one
yes I'm gonna go up the ladder again cuz
screw that guy if I go on the other pipe
then I might be able to find something
there's just one more cog and then
there's the series of series of levers
aha this is what I'm talking about oh
come on give you up ha ha
I'm still alive give me up there good
lord
geez okay loud down it down him god
okay tell me that were dead
ah dang gosh dang it we'll get that all
right I got to find a last cogwheel
don't know where look I got the first
one right here the second one was under
the stairs so the last one must be over
here somewhere
Wow really
I hurt my steel falling ah there it is I
got it I got it I got it
get out here where you doesn't matter
you're a dick
I got it I got it I got it I got it get
in there get in there get on that there
we go go get out there okay so I got all
those now this is lever
oh there's a note I remember this is a
note about this scenery twelve kilovolts
okay so this one can do five and two ah
very interesting
boop-boop boop-boop
PIPP there we go machine is running
shooter he's running here how much what
to do now
what do I do now
I was supposed to do that but what am I
supposed to do when that happen this
great big sound
why did I get to follow that up all good
questions all right okay see anything at
the fog hi how'd you know how's that
was I supposed to do after that
I don't think so because I think Euler
you think there's other stuff house was
a do Neve not here
ah what done oh the goop awesome what
the hell ah startled me
I'm so startled alright still carrying
on still doing five about that cake the
detail right
how do I open that
nope nope no no no no nope
oh there's a lover right there okay all
right I got the lever dick OOP yeah oh
so pro oh so Oh problem all right
so huh man I'm telling you this this
custom story does not let up it is kind
of intense outside very generic huh also
the description on the picture the
loading screen is outside but what could
be waiting for me outside and now I'm
outside
that was some basement for that house
someone seriously
it's gotta be here right we need to
sleep somewhere this night let's visit
Henricks bull what what
it's out here oh I remember that
Oh
ah
that's about it
that's better
are probably like
I'm not gonna
hey about it I was going ah no I picked
up a hammer now what do I need a hammer
for this boat here escape not anymore I
can't
what the deal is I mean I probably was
supposed to follow the road and all that
but I never do that there's exploring to
do I wouldn't have found the hammer if I
didn't explore was that Oh modern
lighting oh yeah
cuidado con el pezzo the gate is loud
how about a hammer papi maybe you could
build a ladder with all the scattered
plants to climb over the fence okay
uh-huh all right I could just climb the
fence
I'm awfully strong yeah okay so I need a
I'm assuming these hammers for that I
saw some planks somewhere over here
remember ah here we go this is a plank
boink boink
uh those aren't good planks okay the
planks are good enough first let me see
what I need to do with these planks hmm
literally just building the ladder my
spy hand or what I know I'm not a gonna
be sure what's going on here
we got there I'll put that just dare I
put that dare sass latter usin Hatcher
shut up
Abby I need five more planks anyway okay
here's some more this is so weird I I'm
really not sure exactly what they want
me to do with these once I get them
there but I'll try
ah
sin-shoo not sure yes unlatch here drag
it out here and then move this over just
squeeze all right there we go it's a
ladder kind of and I'm not sure I'm not
sure what's going on maybe if I hammer
them together nope can't use that item
that way I don't know what I'm expecting
to happen if it's like an igloo as soon
as I put all them steps right on top of
each other but it told me to make a
ladder this is minecraft right totally
totally alright so looking for maybe
there's some more planks I don't know
probably
boink plenty of oil really glad I have
plenty of oil
okay so
I'm over here
No
anything over here just that hammer as I
say carl gustaf 12 6 10 1998 well here's
why I think you're great hmm I think
that's all of them fine anymore so it
said maybe you could build a ladder with
all the scattered place climb over the
fence all right if you say so
I mean you know what you're doing game
right right right
oh lordy Lou oh god oh my oh my don't oh
yeah that's perfect
what oh all right
hey how about that quick yeah like a
mouse point yeah just like that
and boom there we go pro ladder building
skills let me tell you I don't know bad
I like that it's awfully unique for the
MU - this is a full conversion mod so
you can do extra stuff with full
conversion oh this looks good
Hey look at dagger lockpick knife haha
that says careful with the dog by the
way beware of dog beware of the dog
sorry would be a more accurate okay so I
have it right I was not expecting why I
knew it was probably to be the Manama
haha
oh no Bobby no
no Bobby no Bobby no no that's not even
fair that's how deep it fair how's that
fair
all right so anyway
not the help Wow
I failed it LaLanne jump climb over
all right the door is unlocked I just
need to get to it I'm wondering how you
hide from this thing
ah where is it oh there it is oh wait is
there more than one oh there are more
than one there is are more than one oh
boy
I'm so screwed I'm so screwed I'm gonna
get on that rock and I'll hide on the
rock ha I can't get me on my rock my
rock these dead sons of [ __ ]
I just got to keep trying to I just got
to run up and try to get that door open
because hiding and running does not seem
to work I just got to get the door open
uh-uh not good not fun times ow
ha ha ha run run run run run where
run where I don't know don't see them
jump on the car
ah you be on my car I think
okay
they give me a like are they still there
I hear the noises okay I'm gonna assume
that assume that I'm relatively safe so
I'm gonna hand the episode here so thank
you all so much for watching
uh-huh
thank you all so much for watching and
as always we'll see you well in the next
episode bye bye hello everybody my name
is markiplier and welcome back to let's
play just bone in chia these are the
other noises silat my ears
what come down down down down please
your dogs are chasing me oh oh please
let me in I'm begging you I'm begging
you man ah I'm dying
umm I'm dying I died
thank you what wha wha what well wait a
minute wait a minute wah wah wah
wait a minute
really really
really that was the end look I don't
know here she won't give out what I'm
like so confused right now oh man
they're just like oh that is that is
such a weird ending I mean I feel so bad
now because I I stopped the other
episode like right then and there
um I might just like if these are really
the end I might just Stitch the two into
one big episodes so man that is so weird
I was expecting so much more ah I I
guess that's it so ignore the last thing
cuz I am definitely a sissies yes is
only gonna be like two minutes so anyway
ignore that so thank you all so much for
watching this is this was discipline NC
I mean other than that ending it was
going great I mean I really like the the
unique stuff they did in the game but
anyway give it a try the download link
is in the description below as always so
thank you all so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye